Well welcome we are in the world's first
National Videogame Arcade museum
I'm the director , I'm one of the folks that work here.
This what you see when you come in,
The first thing you see when you come in is a massive
blue hedgehog
This wall over here will tell you all the game that are in here.
It changes all the time, so there is tonnes to play.
It's not all about playing games,
but its also about making games
The big thing about this place is we think everyone should be able to play games
But also we really like, people learning how to make them too.
You see these fantastic people at this desk
they'll so hello to you just like this
Hi. Good day.
See exactly like that
There are arcade machines to play,
there are old things to do too.
And then, another kind of peculiar thing about this building is
There is lots of stuff that's only here
So a lot of games that we've commissioned
you can only play in this building
The first one that you'll see is this one
Which is called "Dash and Bash"
So this is only in the National Vidoegame Arcade
Its made by a guy called Alistair Aitcheson
Its a fantastic game that allows you to
to spot these symbols and you have to
bash other people out of the way
and bash the buttons, to get to the right one
before anyone else does.
So we really wanted to write away, show people
that games aren't just about kind of standing like this.
They can be about bashing things too
And that's want we really want to do with this
and lots of people do this as a kind of warm up
You might want to come through here
To the Toast bar, now its not just a clever name
The Toast bar is called the Toast bar
Mind the step
because it will, it has a variety of toasts that it will indeed venue.
And lots again of games for you to play
Tends too be the older stuff in here, Nintendo 64
You can request a different game from the bar if you want to.
In the summer, cause' it's nice in the summer right
You can sit outside and play a game
and eat some toast
To try and welcome you as much as we possibly can.
So coming over here
So this is "Mission Control"
Its a game about making games
So the idea here is, it's a two player game
and whilst two people play it, other people
other people can be changing it
So you can change the graphics
You can change the gravity
You can change the spawn rate of aliens
Kind of really gently, get people into the idea that
That they can change
what games are
and really see what games are made of
So a weird thing about games is that you
not often get
not often get a look inside the kitchen
of what they are
Other things that are just here this is "Room Racers"
This is a fantastic game by Lieven van Velthoven
This is like micro machines
but the magical part of it is
I'll just start this up for you.
I'm the red car here racing around
But this is the cool part, any thing we put down
the car crashes into
So you end up with a couple of different games happening
One of them is like a racing game
another will be people lying on here
to be raced around
anything we put there the car can't pass through
So its about two things, its about playing games
and racing cars, but its also about what makes a good race track
This is our big main stairwell,
that goes up and down most of the buildings.
and when you design a museum often what people do
is try and hide the computers, and hide the way that it works
and we kind of when the opposite way
we want to expose everything
even if you don't know about electronics
you can see that all of the orange stuff
is power, all of the purple is network
So similarly the exhibits that we built here
if they break, and they DO break sometimes
we just fix them in front you
because you can, because you can do that
We are trying to capture the spirit of, when I was a kid
if the video recorder broke we would have the back off
on the kitchen table
you could put it back together again
but you would have a go at fixing it
Its that kind of idea of being able to open stuff up
an X-Ray it and really get invovled
is what we are trying to do.
The whole building, we wanted to make transparent
So gallery two is the hall of inputs
It ranges from the kind of controllers that
you are used to having at home
The game of trials, with a quite complicated
but none the less, thing you might recognise
the XBox controller
to arcade macines
So joysticks and buttons, you'll be familiar with what they are.
to mouse and keyboard games
"Indian Jones and the fate of Atlantis"
fantastic adventure game. Text adventures with "Twine"
To light gun games with, "Time Crisis" and "Duck Hunt"
Cockpit games, so driving games, we've got "Star Wars" or "Sonic Racing"
To the music rooms
There is "Rock band" or "Guitar Heroes" which can get a bit out of hand.
it can get quite loud in this room from time to time.
This is one of my favorite bits, this is a wall of inputs.
So there are four games, all with quite different
control mechanisms
So we've got
a version of a game called "Tempest"
which is using a spinner,
which you spin round and shot the aliens
So a single button game
OHH, I'm not very good at it though.
Terrible at this game.
And a track ball game, "Missile Command"
Some of you may remember this
So your moving the cross-hair around
with the track ball
So they are all played in quite different ways
and what we are trying to do is, in a really gentle way
is get people to think about
that not all games are
controlled with a
kind of controller that you might have at home
there is loads and loads of different
of interfaces of games
so by gently, we change this around quite often
we change the games around,
we change the controllers around
to gently draw attention to the fact that
the assumptions that you might have about video games
that might not necessarily be true
Because a lot of people either play with a keyboard and mouse
or they play with a game pad
and there are so many different things that games are
So we have smaller installations in these rooms
so these change around every few months
we will put a different kind of more experiential game in there.
Right now it is "Panoramical"
which is a generative music game.
like the late 60's on a wall.
And then we move up to gallery three
So this is our most kind of gallery like gallery, I guess.
The problem of exhibiting video games
the problem of talking to people about video games,
is that quite often
they rely on you as a customer being good at video games.
So if I wanted to talk to you about
Sonic the hedgehog, right.
and show you what Sonic the hedgehog is
I could hand you a controller and let you play
Sonic the hedgehog and hope that you are go at Sonic the hedgehog.
because if you're not then you want be able to see those bits.
So what we are trying to do with this Game inspector
Is experiment with giving people snapshots of
specific ideas within games to experience
So this is "Gang Beasts",
if you havent played "Gang Beasts"
you must immediately get "Gang Beasts"
it's been in made Sheffield
It's a kind of drunk jelly babies
fighting in a carpark, physics brawler game.
By a company called "Boneloaf"
the guys at "Boneloaf" made for us
a Game inspector. This is a demo
showing you playing the game over there
and over here you can play
with seeing how the physics works
You can see he turns red at the collision points
And you can also see how the animation works
You can see what this person is actually doing
rolling around on a ball
which when animated
you can get a much better scence of the movement
So this is a look inside the game
that you are playing, that you would never normally see
One of the things that I always liked about
exhibts, classical things, Is the sketchbooks
rather than the finished things
they're working it out, how big is the head meant to be
So in here we invite any developer
to show work thats not finished yet
People get to play stuff before its done
they leave them suggestions
in the feed the developers box
So people get to see games before they're done
and give feed back
and say things like: it should be faster or slower,
or it's too hard or the colours aren't right.
And it's a look inside games that most of the public never really get.
Most times you encounter a game it's been shrink wrapped
and it's finished and its beautiful.
Just exposing this fact that
they are things that aren't made
It's really really important.
This is the Green house
And then our most gallery like gallery
this is our history of video games
in 100 at least objects,
roughly 100 objects.
And its a loosly chronolgical journey
Starting here, so whenever people come in,
they will gravitate to the area they recogonise.
So this would be my childhood
right here.
And again these are all machines that people can play,
we have a bit of BASIC on the window,
if people want to have a go at programming the BBC.
I'm always really delighted and surprised
at the amount of time people spend in here.
I think that people of a certain age, like me,
we spend quite a lot of time along this wall
we are trying to show the social history of games too.
So thing like, and this may not mean much to some of you,
things like pirated cassettes, from the 80's
with hand drawn, school boy artwork.
things like maps from video games,
things like spin off board games, and keyboard overlays.
A kind of ephemera of what games are,
and what games meant to people
is really what this room is trying to capture.
This isn't just about, again, playing things
but also things like "Larazade"
donated by no less than Ian Livingston
DOOM 2 master.
Like a couple of weeks ago, John Romero turned up here.
So John Romero was a co-designer of DOOM
the semial first-person shooter
and this is one of the gold masters of DOOM 2
An incredibly influential designer
and just rocked up,
First thing I knew of it was, I was at home,
First thing we heard about it somebody on our
we have this thing called 'Slack'
that we use for internal message
OH MY GOD! John Romero is in the building
and everyone went nuts,
he did a little talk here for some
of the Dads how recognized who he was
It was a very special moment
People tend to spend most of the day here,
when they come, that combined with
things like the classes
if you've got kids that want to learn how to code
they come on a Saturday morning
heaps of extra stuff during the week
and lots and lots of events happening in the evening.
For every group
we are trying to be
a community centre, really.
For people who are interested in this kind of stuff
If you are interested in football you can join a football club
If you are interested in music you can join an orchestra.
If you are interested in games, or technology,
or interested in culture
come here and help us make it better
So that's the National Videogame Arcade